as isis is rampaging across Iraq and
Syria the emir of mosul had some
interesting things to say about their
grand plans this is nothing we're just
at the beginning up until now we've used
just a small part of the forces that we
have at our disposition you cannot
imagine how strong we really are we have
immense power you will be amazed you
won't be able to defeat us and he goes
on
we've never feared the Americans not
even in the past when they were in a
weaker position why on earth do you
think we would fear them now we've
beaten them before and we'll beat them
again Allah curse the Americans and
their allies they will come to a very
bed and so I think a lot of this is
probably just posturing and all this
stuff but do we have to take any of this
seriously knows this part of that you
know uh Ralph Harris the famous atheist
says that you know it's a it takes
religion to make men do things that are
horrible like this right to cut
someone's head off to kill 40,000 people
so would you say this is a part as its
religion or is this what what would use
I would say that this is again one part
of the bad parts of religion right yeah
I would agree I mean I think it's
probably 75% religion 25% of our
policies that propped up awful people to
repress their own people and this is
what you get yeah I don't know the only
issue to me only relevant question is
what we do now and you know if these
guys you know we saw there that was we
we know they know I'm Scalia there like
that words gonna know that words gonna
call it sexy back answer some reasons
not a yeah oh yeah that's right baby
so like if they're 700 of these guys or
1700 or 2700 we should bomb a living
[ __ ] out uh especially if they're in the
open uh you know we're not is this is
not gossip these are this is not a
densely populated city where kids and
women and children live in innocent men
so strike while you can because maybe
that will do the trick
if they're stronger than that then we're
gonna have to deal with them uh I don't
think any of us want to go fight a war
against them uh and send in American
troops and send in 75,000 American
troops to fight these guys there uh
because they'll win in the long run
they'll win abilities if they live they
then we wanna go home so uh you hope
that you can build a political
diplomatic coalition of Arab neighbors
and friends and allies uh who will help
you to politically isolate these guys I
don't know if that's or civil wars
raging that's very hard to do right so
do you that just doesn't exist though it
doesn't seem to be right unless you
unless you really have oil companies
wanting it to happen remember when
George Bush went crazy trying to get the
Coalition of the Willing hey we've got
36 countries with it but that wasn't a
real coalition so we need to put
together a real coalition like a real un
again I mean that's what really needs to
happen you need to have a bunch of
countries and they're fighting against
them but this is the world against them
yeah it seems to me that that's gone
like this thing with Yazidis on the
mountain yeah if there were everyone who
there were 40,000 people sitting up
there starving to death
they were surrounding the mountain Isis
and everyone was saying what are we
gonna do what are we gonna do and it's
like well obviously only you the United
States was gonna do it so this is like
our curse right this is now our curse
well why wouldn't Saudi Arabia do
something why wouldn't another countries
I just don't think they I think every
right to the US will come in and clean
up the mess but it's becoming a problem
on the streets of Europe we've got an
interesting image out of Holland
these are Isis flags being flown in
Holland so what are these this is
happening now there have been Isis flags
in London they've been in Paris like
what is happening here and you know
Europe has this major immigration
problem especially France because
they've led in a lot of people that
didn't get integrated society properly
what are you supposed to do I mean we
don't have it here in America
I saw there was one in New Jersey
actually that right there was one guy
remember after 9/11 the football player
from the Phoenix Cardinals I forget his
name now Tillman had Tillman I was so up
you know he got so worked up and he went
and he volunteered because he wanted to
go kill some al-qaeda for other America
yeah I literally that's how I feel about
these Isis guys and they really haven't
even done anything to us yeah that guy I
swear God I'm walking my dog I'm like a
fighter God I would join I look over
there start shooting some em efforts
yeah so what are you making what are the
European supposed to do this stuff it
seems like it's growing there now
they're not they're not beheading it but
the flags it's like who who in their
right mind lives in a western country
and is somehow
acting that I get you know anymore
evolving because I'm not getting it well
clearly you have to be a serious
practicing Muslim to begin with right
so only say and and to some extent
somewhat fundamentalist the difference
that the thing that we can't do is look
at people in Holland with a flag who are
saying look at the guys who've been in
their mind perhaps pushed around forever
yet right and now are standing up and
our men are winning we never win and
here we are in this stage winning
because the West has already left and
what we can't do is presume that these
guys hold the flags well we have to be
wary of it but we can presume these guys
all the flags are ready to take up arms
in any way most of these people gonna go
back home and cook dinner and go to
their jobs in the next morning but they
like the fact that they're winning free
speech and everything with you know to
me it's like the same thing if you carry
around a KKK yeah or not or swastika
it's like this is only about hate and
killing it's the most heinous thing we
are terrorism we're the embodiment of it
we're trying to scare the [ __ ] out of
the world so it's like you want to scare
the [ __ ] out of me well how about I try
to scare the [ __ ] out of you back
because we can well I think partly
they're empowered because I think they
think that you're just gonna do know
that so the but it's gonna come down to
what do they do if they are able to
succeed because at some point the only
way they're gonna keep anyone in any of
those places happy and by the way
they're gonna kill though mostly who
they kill of course are Muslims like at
some point that's gonna bother that's
what I did about everyone everyone else
right so at but again it depends on
whether you're Sunni or Shia but that
but at some point they're gonna have to
open school and they're gonna have to
run water to people and they're gonna
have to provide basic services yes and
they have to prove that they can do that
right now they've just hired a bunch of
thugs to go cut people's heads off i I
don't know that that like that that
video is gonna scare us of the severed
head I suspect that that as we see more
that it will also scare plenty of people
it's a easy transition from head
severing to roads and transportation
[Music]